this is salaam studio toilets i feel
embarrassed i swear to god i feel
embarrassed when guests come to do
videos
for for them to come here and use the
toilet check this out
this is our toilet guys yeah it's
embarrassing
not an animal deserves to live here let
alone human beings how we're going to
ask our guests to come and do what we do
here
no hot water freezing cold disgusting
but with our new studio check the
toilets out
guys isn't hot water amazing of course
it is
and this is our new toilets in our new
studio
finally imagine a group of muslims going
into christian lands
kicking the christians out of their
lands taking their homes
very powerful and it's a message
directly from allah to the palestinians
check out our sponsors nature's blends
they specialize in premium ethiopian
black seed products
the website is in the description link
below you can also use the discount code
salam 10 for 10 of their products
assalamu alaikum today better care to
your brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are well inshallah
as you guys know subhanallah ramadan has
been very busy uh for all of us and
subhanallah i've been seeing what's
going on in palestine
and subhanallah i wanted to uh raise uh
awareness to this japanese sisters and
with these matters i have to be very
careful because i just don't want to
jump on the trend everyone's talking
about let me talk about it as well you
know i genuinely
want to do this as well subhanallah why
because allah subhanahu wa speaks
directly to the palestinian subhanallah
and we can see the oppression that's
taking place brothers and sisters
imagine a group of muslims going into
christian lands kicking the christians
out of their lands
taking their homes attacking them
killing them
imagine this was non-born sisters yeah
the western world like to liberate the
muslim world by muslim rulers
imagine what they would have done if the
muslims were doing this and you can see
the hypocrisy
of the christians some christians not
all because allah says in the quran
you know not all the christians are the
same you know the people of the book um
and subhanallah you can see that the
these people and jewish people not all
of them
zionists as well specifically
subhanallah that absolute hypocrisy and
they turn an absolute blind eye when
this muslim's blood they don't care
alhamdulillah we have the hereafter
you're going to stand in front of god
and allah tell us a message
our last one that has a message to the
palestinians and to the syrians and to
the
in china all your muslim brothers and
sisters and in burma
yes around the world that are being
possibly persecuted and killed
can you imagine we are muslims have been
slaughtered
millions and they dare to call us
the terrorists unbelievable anyways
allah's message is very categorically
clear
in the quran chapter 42 verse 39 i'm
going to read a couple of verses
inshallah
and inshallah i'm going to give you guys
the translations very powerful and it's
a message directly from allah to the
palestinians
keep strong defend yourselves no one can
say anything even
i'm going to come to this a bit later uh
even under the u.n law
you have a right the person have a right
to defend themselves inshallah they
should do that inshallah
allah says
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and those who and those who when tyranny
strikes them
they retaliate in a just manner and the
retribution for an evil act
is an evil one like it but whoever
pardons and makes reconciliation
his reward is with allah indeed he does
not like the wrongdoers
and whoever retaliates after having been
wronged those have not upon them any
cause for blame there is no sin or blame
on you
defending yourself the cause is only
against the one who is
who wronged the people and tyrannized
upon and tyrant
wrong people and tyrannized upon the
earth without right
those will have a painful punishment and
whoever
is patient and forgive indeed that is
matters
worthy of praise subhan allah and allah
also says
do not ever think that allah is unaware
of what the evil uh what the um
evil people do he only waits and waits
for the day that they will stare in
horror there's a promise from allah
and bear patience brothers and sisters
bear patients
and this is my message i don't want to
keep it long straight to the point this
is our message to our palestinian
brothers and sisters we are with you we
support you
and we will be here and subhanallah for
those muslim businesses who are selling
israeli dates may allah destroy your
business may allah destroy your business
may allah destroy your business
for those who are selling israeli
products using israeli
zionist products why because you want
some profit and that's where you get
from
shame on you why because you can't go a
palestinian dates are
a little bit expensive may allah destroy
your wealth
this ramadan if you are more concerned
about the money
about making profits and you know these
products from israel
yeah and you try your best we know a lot
of stuff from israel we try our best to
avoid using it
yeah may allah destroy your business
i mean it's as simple as that i'll make
that door inshallah we've done a video
you can watch a couple of years ago me
and
musa we went to um tesco's
and to raise awareness to these blood
dates and was faced with
a few coward zionists yeah their few
cowards died in subhanallah and this is
exactly what's happening in brahman
sisters this is my message
to the online inshallah do not despair
let them have their couple of minutes
because allah under their judgment is
going to say how long do you stay on
earth
one day half a day let them have it
nations have come before and destroyed
millions
thousands of years ago guys time is
flying before we know we're all gonna
die
we're gonna be finished and we're gonna
be raised up have your five minute of
fun
have your five minutes of oppression and
don because you're going to have
eternal life in hell inshallah
brother sisters till next time share
this with your friends and family
youtube might
try to restrict this make sure you share
this
share it so people can hear it inshallah
because we know youtube is going to try
to restrict it inshallah
and i'm trying my best to get it out
there without them restricting it uh
leave that part to me inshaallah but you
guys do your job by sharing it assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuhu